In this course, we have learned about a large number of reasoning methods.
Here are some of them. We could have added a lot more here, for example,
plan refinement or logic or scripts. Typically when you and
I program an AI agent, we pick a method, and we program that
method into the agent. One unanswered question is, how might an agent know about
all of these methods and the autonomously select the right method for
a given problem? This is the problem of strategy selection and
metacognition helps with strategy selection. Given a problem, and given that all
of these matters are relative to the agent to potentially address problem.
Metacognition is select between these matters using several criteria.
First, each of these methods require some knowledge of the world. For example,
case-based reasoning requires knowledge of cases.
Constraint propagation requires knowledge of constraint. And so
on. Metacognition is select one particular method, depending on
what knowledge is exactly available for addressing that specific input problem.
If that specific input problem, case does not have a label, then clearly
the method of case-based reasoning cannot be used. If, on the other hand,
constraints are available, the constraint propagation might be a useful method.
Second, if the knowledge required by multiple methods is available, then
metacognition must select between the competing methods. Under the criteria for
selecting between these methods might be computational efficiency.
For a given class of problems, some of these methods might be
computationally more efficient than other methods. As an example,
if the problem is very close to a previously encountered case, then a case-based
reasoning might be computationally a very good method to use. On the other hand,
if the new problem is very different from a previously encountered case,
then case-based reasoning may not be a computationally efficient method.
We've come across this issue of computational efficiency earlier in this class.
For example, when we were discussing generate and
test. If the problem is simple, then it is potentially possible to
write a generator that will produce good solutions to it. On the other hand, for
a very complex problem, the process of generating good solutions may be
computationally inefficient. Similarly, if there is a single goal,
then the method of means-ends analysis may be a good choice. On the other hand,
if there are multiple goals that are interacting with each other,
the means-ends analysis can run into all kind of cul-de-sacs, and
have poor computational efficiency. A third criteria that metacognition can
use to select between these various methods is quality of solutions.
Some methods come with guarantees of quality of solutions. For example,
logic is a method of provide some guarantees of the correctness of solutions.
Thus, if this is a problem for which computational efficiency is not important,
where the quality of solutions is critical, you might want to use the method of
logic. Because it provides some guarantees of the quality, although it
might be computationally inefficient. The same kind of analysis holds for
selecting between different learning methods. Once again,
given a problem, the agent may have multiple learning methods for
addressing their particular problem. What method should the learning agent
choose? That depends partly on the nature of the problem.
Some methods are applicable to that problem, and some methods may not be
applicable to that problem. Second, for example, in this learning task,
if the examples come in one at a time we might use incremental concept learning.
On the other hand, if all the examples are given together, then we might use
decision-tree learning or identification-tree learning. Another criteria for
deciding between these methods could be computational efficiency that
lay down what the criteria could have to do with quality of solutions.